[Música]
spectrum
soy amalia viviana basanta hernández
naciendo en un seno de una familia
dedicada al arte
mi mamá coreógrafa directora
investigadora creadora desarrolló un
proyecto en el cual yo nací en medio de
ese de ese proyecto al nacer en el seno
de una familia yo no decidí en qué
momento me iba a dedicar al arte oa la
danza simple y sencillamente iba
creciendo en medio de eso que para mí
era parte del alimento cotidiano
construirme no fue decidir en términos
de cuando yo creciera iba a decidir ser
artista o iba a decidir ser coreógrafo o
iba a decidir dedicarme a otra cosa
estudie
en ciencias de la comunicación en la
cual no acabe por irme una gira de seis
meses por mi mamá ella prefería que me
volcara hacia la danza así empecé a la
edad de cuatro años cinco años a
estudiar danza en la escuela de mi mamá
posteriormente entré con la maestra
nelly happy seguía yo tomando danza
tradicional siempre y siempre acompañaba
en muchos momentos a mi mamá a su
proceso de investigación a los pueblos
originarios a las tradiciones a las
fiestas a las celebraciones de los
santos patronos en fin a una gama enorme
donde teníamos contacto con las raíces
que fue lo que hizo vivir más llevar
nuestras tradiciones al mundo y abrir
esa puerta donde no se conocían por qué
hubo un momento en donde el mundo no
tenía el interés que fue empezándose a
crear en relación a méxico y su cultura
fue poco a poco conociendo qué país
éramos un país diverso la diversidad ha
sido finalmente algo que no se nos
describe a los mexicanos así fue
creciendo estudie el ballet clásico con
la maestra nelly happy luego estuve en
ballet nacional estudiando con la
maestra guillermina bravo donde tuve
grandes maestros como rossana filomarino
federico castro valentina castro algunas
maestros que trajeron a méxico como
yuriko y posteriormente mi mamá se
acerca mucho al vinil y cuando se hace
el proyecto de 1968 que era crear un
gran espectáculo que la olimpiada no
fuera nada más y exclusivamente
un elemento deportivo si no se hizo una
olimpiada cultural esa olimpiada
cultural contuvo coreógrafos mexicanos
que fueron a sudamérica centroamérica
y conocer todos los usos y costumbres y
tradiciones y se invitó de todo el mundo
de grecia de turquía de rusia de áfrica
los coreógrafos que representaban y
albín el indigno
representaban a sus países estudie
después ya mucho tiempo con emma pulido
y luego estuve en nueva york con nat
corn estuve estudiando con distintos
maestros
con alvin neil y estuve con milton
majors con una maestra entrenada por
catherine ton hung era realmente una
maravilla esa técnica africana hecha
contemporánea donde funcionaba el pasado
con el presente
estudié también horton donham
y nicola entonces fue aprendiendo con
albín nicolás que era eso que era
improvisar improvisar era usar los
elementos que tú tienes adentro para
poder expresar lo que te van guiando
porque a veces como maestros de
improvisación técnica
te van guiando dibuja líneas en el
espacio y tú las dibujas como quieres
dibuja círculos gira usa los niveles que
hay en que hay en un espacio cómo
construir un espacio cómo construir un
elementos que te van dando el resultado
de una improvisación que te puede llevar
a una composición y que te puede llevar
posteriormente algo creativo pero donde
construimos la diversidad la diversidad
la construimos aceptando al ser humano
no le podemos poner título a cada quien
porque sino nada más nos auto dividimos
mucho más en lugar de construir sino en
bar darnos cuenta que lo diferente no se
enriquece si yo estoy con alguien
diferente a mí voy a aprender algo de
esa persona entonces yo creo que la
diversidad es hablarle hoy al ser humano
y ese y tenerle respeto como
lo que sea lo que siente en lo que vive
y lo que desea
si hay si hay un respecto vamos a tener
una mejor evolución y posteriormente me
fui al alabar al alabar no aprenderás la
notación color coreográfica pero sí
aprender cuál eran los procesos porque
ellos tienen un proceso creativo muy
interesante
ese proceso creativo de mantener un
salón
en el cual no hay espejos y tú tienes
que empezar a construir lo que están
diciendo y finalmente a veces juegan con
tus emociones que es lo que es jugar con
las emociones que te digan demuestran
que tú quieres ir con movimiento a algún
lado sin decírmelo o que rechazas algo
que te va a llegar o dibujar una línea
visual en el espacio donde entonces tú
le des a la vista la energía que
realmente tiene a tus manos la energía
que realmente tiene si yo quiero dirigir
mi energía sea ya ni siquiera tengo que
ir puedo voltear y dirigir mi mano y
lanzar mi energía en una dirección y
empecé a entender que también se podía
construir a través de la energía de las
emociones del proceso creado hoy yo
estoy trabajando con la comunidad
afroamericana en denver colorado en en
cuestiones contemporáneas
y a mí siempre me ha parecido a una
comunidad extraordinariamente
maravillosa cuando albín el living a
méxico yo era muy pequeña pero logró
impregnar una parte de mí donde yo me
identifique muchísimo con su técnica con
su trabajo mi otro proceso de
crecimiento fue empezar a ir con mi mamá
ya no nada más en términos de una niña
que acompañaba a su mamá sino
aprendiendo realmente qué es lo que
pasaba en méjico pasaba que a veces
nosotros los mismos mexicanos no le
dábamos el valor a nuestros pueblos
originarios ya nuestras artes ya nuestra
artesanía porque para mí en muchos
momentos no es solo artesanía es
realmente un proceso creativo un y
descriptivo describe en su vida su forma
su los trabajos la fia aprendiendo a
respetar mis raíces respetar nuestro
país respetar nuestras tradiciones
nuestras creencias nuestros usos y
costumbres y a valorar lo que nuestros
pueblos indígenas nos dan nos dan
representatividad en el mundo nos han
dado han abierto muchas puertas porque
finalmente méxico la cultura de méxico
es lo que ha creado interés por venir a
conocer desde nuestra época prehispánica
hasta nuestros días y aquí yo estoy como
muy
dispuesta a seguir como luchando y
defendiendo a nuestros pueblos
originarios que ojalá tengan una mejor
vida pero al mismo tiempo que no pierdan
lo que son ni su arte mis artesanía ni
su cosmogonía ni su entendimiento de la
tierra y del cielo me fui a la dirección
general de los tecnológicos industriales
que eran services betis donde había un
encuentro nacional de arte y cultura ese
encuentro tenía un proceso municipal
de pequeñas comunidades estatal y luego
el federal no me tocó ser 22 años jurado
del encuentro de art y cultura y se va
construyendo un movimiento gigante en en
los deje de ser los cetis y el nose
betis tanto que hoy muchos de los
coreógrafos que pasaron por los cetis y
cbtis son coreógrafos ya conocidos
internacionalmente muy buenos una
diversidad yo veía a alguien de campeche
y de yucatán pero ellos alguien de
tabasco y ya no se parecía de yucatán
sin embargo a estaba en donde hay una
parte del tratamiento también en tabasco
donde uno va encontrando parte de cómo
se fue tejiendo este méxico
diverso y
un méxico que tiene muchos lenguajes que
yo creo que todavía falta saber
aprovechar esos distintos lenguajes que
tiene nuestro país y así me fui auto
construyendo hoy hago coreografía hoy
tengo proyectos distintos que estoy
realizando estoy yéndome a eeuu trabajos
con las comunidades mexicanas y algunas
americanas además de la afroamericana
donde trabajo una parte contemporánea
con lenguaje mexicano y nuestra
influencia también de la tercera raíz
hice un proyecto en danza contra paraná
que se llamó la leyenda a la mulata de
córdoba yo oí situación uno que le
digamos los cuatro viajes al ford
service que tiene que ver con la nau de
china
somos uno de los países más ricos del
mundo en cuestión de trajes
tradicionales en cuestión de gastronomía
en cuestión de folklore en cuestión de
artesanía es totalmente distinta a la
artesanía del surf
del sureste del centro del norte del
noroeste son muy distintas muy distintos
nuestros pueblos indígenas los indígenas
tarahumaras son los indígenas de baja
california al norte son muy distintos
alude a los indígenas de chiapas de
nuestro que se aparte se expresan de
manera distinta y a veces ves que se
expresan hasta cómo es su vegetación son
más rudos en el norte son muchos muy
frondosos en el sur en un tiempo que de
hecho venían artistas el lunes el grafo
que tuvo mi mamá que se llamó robin von
inglés
que vino aquí a méxico con la esperanza
de poder desarrollar su trabajo y lo
desarrolló fantásticamente entonces yo
creo que es en méxico que ofrece
distintas cosas a veces no lo vemos no
lo vemos porque estamos inmersos en las
noticias en las cuestiones negativas
pero yo creo que si buscamos construir a
base de lo bueno que tenemos a base de
lo que sí podemos hacer de lo que sí
podemos desarrollar no puede ser que
tengamos esa riqueza y no la sé no
sabemos qué hacer con ella mismo creo
que nos falta ser más creativos y yo en
el proceso en la educación en lo que
están los estudiantes y lo busquen
busquen su propio proceso creativo yo
como artista estoy acostumbrada a buscar
inspiración en las distintas fuentes de
información y estoy yendo continuamente
eeuu porque creo
un momento donde los jóvenes que venían
de familias mexicanas algunos ya nacidos
hay algunos que se fueron se había un
rechazo hacia su historia o hacia su
cultura entonces una de mis metas era ir
generando como esa empatía con su
cultura con su historia con la riqueza
de donde vienen no con lo que hizo que
se fueran de aquí sino con lo que si
vale la pena recabar reconstruir y
retomar sin embargo que siempre le
agradezcan ese gran país que les abrió
las puertas y se las abre de una forma
maravillosa tanto que hoy en san antonio
nomás hay 100 compañías de danza
tradicional mexicana y algunos ya tienen
sus propios lenguajes obviamente viene
un mestizaje distinto porque no lo
pueden traer nada más trajo tal cual
está aquí finalmente ellos ya viven
también de otra forma y construyen de
otra forma piensan
en base a lo que han ido aprendiendo y
estudiando entonces esa conjunción de no
tengo que rechazar esto por aceptar esto
sino estos dos pilares que tengo en mi
vida como me ayudan a ir hacia un camino
hay 300 compañías en los ángeles no sé
si si contabilizamos en todo eeuu lo que
las cantidad de compañías que hablan de
méxico ya en su propia forma de entender
a nuestro país y al mismo tiempo hoy por
hoy disfrutan de un país que al abrirle
las puertas les permitió mejorar cierta
calidad de vida entonces yo creo que hay
de todo y a mí algo que he aprendido que
se me hace maravilloso las compañías
allá no son como aquí de que vamos
bailamos ensayamos y nos conocemos y
hacemos amigos se vuelven como una
comunidad una comunidad social donde las
mamás
llevar los sandwiches en los papas
llevan las aguas en la pareja este baile
bordar las flores no hay discriminación
no tienen nada que ver quienes a veces
está el eso nada se vuelve una comunidad
que se acepta se quiere se ayuda se
apoye se construye formemos un proceso
creativo en nosotros mismos y siempre a
los que nos tenemos que superar es a
nosotros mismos y no el que tengo
enfrente tengo que superar mis
limitaciones saber cuáles son que me
falta aprender para superar la acción no
creo en un ser humano estas son mis
limitaciones y jaime que no creo no lo
creo creo que siempre tener una
posibilidad de seguir construyendo no
importa el tiempo que estemos yo hasta
el día de hoy sigo aprendiendo aprendo
mucho de mi gente y sigo aprendiendo
mucho de mis maestros de mata amigos
hay muchos amigos que estamos
relacionados en cuestión de danza y arte
que somos grupos
fuerte es que nos ayudamos nos
acompañamos signos y ya compartimos
información y entonces pues ojalá esto
les sirva para llegar a un proceso
creativo en la carrera en la que se
encuentren y que se construyan un futuro
que crea que los haga sentir la
satisfacción de poder hacer lo que
quieren y lo que desean hacer